let's start with the jets they have the
second and 23rd overall pick the 23rd
pick courtesy of the seahawks as part of
the jamal adams trade 10 total picks
tied for third most in the draft
the jets can't leave draft weekend
without
addressing what chris i think the
biggest one for me mike is corner that's
the one place i look at their roster and
not to say i mean again we know
at pick number two they're taking zach
wilson but you go later down the first
round pick 23 that could be you know
corner territory when you get into that
conversation there but that's the one
thing i look at their roster to go
there there's nothing there as of right
now to make you feel comfortable as a
head coach a defensive coordinator right
there to where you think you got a guy
that could cover any you know top-tier
type receiver in a big situation
man-to-man let alone even though i know
they're going to be a very big zone team
really not even proven commodities that
you can trust in that aspect yet either
there in that chest roster so that's why
i go corner more than any other position
if caleb farley slips down oh 23. oh got
one of those where you sprint to the
podium you sprint you dive you know you
tackle the guy making the announcement
you go hurry up speak this out of your
mouth now like yeah and that's you know
that'll be interesting with caleb farley
with some of the issues he's got you
know we talked about it last week the
kobet opt out two back surgeries all of
that will he be on the board there at
that time that would be unbelievable but
yeah i would think somewhere in this
first two rounds the jets definitely
exhaust one of their they have four
picks i believe right in the first two
rounds one of them is going to be on a
corner i would i would be shocked if no
i think though that if you're going to
use the second overall pick on a
potential franchise quarterback the guy
that would be the first to a franchise
quarterback since joe namath you got to
have some help around him and and and
you got to help him have the ability to
get the ball to the help that's around
him the offensive line still not where
it needs to be i know makai bechten was
a great addition right last year but
that's one guy
one thing we've learned left tackle
isn't the end all be all because you got
four other spots on the offensive line
that could stink all you need to find is
one that becomes the sieve through which
the defense pours its way into the
backfield but whether it's offensive
line whether it's and you don't have to
reach you don't have to go 23rd overall
pick on a receiver or a running back no
you you but but that that's i i just
think remember last year it was all
defensive draft for the panthers i
wouldn't be upset if the jets went all
offensive draft this year now 10 picks
you could get a defensive player from
time to time but they got to go heavy on
offense to put weapons around zach
wilson yeah i mean listen i would think
that's going to be
a big focus they spent a lot of money in
free agency on the defensive side of the
ball to where that mic to like what
you're saying right there that seems to
be the plan of attack and
you know
they got a lot of flexibility there end
of the first round early second those
picks there when you talk about pick 23
and then pick 34
yeah you could distribute that any way
you want you know really you should have
a really quality receiver corner or
offensive lineman on the board
at either one of those picks in round
two and really in round three i think
you really still got a chance of getting
some quality offensive linemen and a
good receiver in that round as well with
those two picks so uh they should be
able to bolster their roster but you're
i'm excited to see their their approach
all together mike and i would think that
yes like let's not make the mistake
we've talked about or that they made
with sam darnold you're gonna draft a
quarterback at two you know start start
giving them lots of weapons to play with
you know they did that with corey davis
a receiver and free agency they could
certainly add some more
yep and it's that balance between adding
receivers and running backs versus
adding offensive linemen because you got
to protect the franchise quarterback if
he indeed becomes one miami dolphins
sixth and eighteenth picks in round one
two second round picks four picks in the
top 50.
they can't leave draft weekend without
addressing what chris i mean i i think
it's a wide receiver i think at some
point you know and again i would expect
it to be
somewhere in the first round with one of
those two picks that we see one of the
top receivers come off the board to them
uh that to me would be the big thing
again we just talked about it yeah you
got a young quarterback you want to make
it work you know it didn't look great
that first year you want to get people
like me who question you know tua and
how successful he can be start putting
some people that are talented around him
so i think that's where i look at you
know the the dolphins more than anything
and go no they need a a big play
play-making you know
wide receiver catch catch guy whatever
maybe that's a kyle pitts
as a pass catcher but uh but i would
think it's somebody that can make two in
the pass game more dangerous
i i'd like to see them much like i feel
with the steelers get a running back and
i know that this isn't yeah the the
brian flores way because it's not the
patriot way they like to have a
revolving door of a bunch of running
backs and that makes sense from health
concern it makes sense from financial
concern
but sometimes like when you're trying to
boost a young quarterback if you get a
badass
tailback who can be on the field every
down who is going to help energize your
offense that way and you you run to set
up the pass
it makes it easier for tua to set up and
pass if you have a running back that's
going to put defenses on their heels and
there's always guys who come out and
make an impact right away you got to
block for them you got to hope they know
how to hold onto the football you got to
trust them with blitz pickups but if if
you get one of those guys and i'm not
saying round one round two yeah you got
those two second round picks wait till
round two get a guy who can come in and
really help take the heat off of the
passing game i think that's what they
need to do i i i hear you there there's
no doubt you know listen they invested
some some key keep key pieces in the
draft last year in the offensive line
you know they they drafted a first round
left tackle from usc
a first round you know guard slash
tackle at a louisiana tech
they gave jesse davis one of their
offensive linemen a little more money
and when at the end of the season or
right when the season ended so they are
set up as far as the offensive line to
you know be better and better and i'm
with you and then i think you know to
your point mike yeah where they're
sitting i'm just trying to make sure
here that i'm seeing this right like the
dolphins are what pick 50 in the second
round
you know yeah there's going to be a good
running back on the board for them to
take but i i'm with you there that is
definitely a need for their football
team right now there's no like guy you
look at their roster right mike where
you go oh wait that's the guy they're
good they're good at the running back
position they're definitely not good
they need a difference maker i'm with
you there all the way
all right new england patriots have the
15th overall pick that doesn't happen
very often here's coach bill belichick
from last week meeting with reporters
do we have the do we have the
belichick sound we don't have the bell
okay we'll get the belichick sound the
belichick sound is coming we will we
will fill until the belichick sound is
ready happy birthday by the way on a
belated burst on a belated basis to bill
belichick now we have bill belichick
from last week talking about the
patriots uncharacteristically drafting
in the mid part of round one i think
that it
again each draft's a little bit
different and and
so each year is a little bit different
but all that being said
um
you know at 15 i think we could
eliminate a few players that won't be at
15
and then you could look at a couple
scenarios and say well if
you know these three players are there
which one we take if
these other three different players were
there which one would you take you know
you go through that exercise and
and and talk about that but i would say
normally
something now there's less options at 15
than there are
you know 28 30 31
you know some other spots that we
drafted from but
um
i would say normally something will
happen and and there could very well be
a player there that
uh either
you don't expect to be there or
maybe he
is a couple spots maybe at 12 13 he's
still on the board
and he really thought that he'd be gone
in the top six seven picks
and then that and you know then the
question comes you know do you move up
and try to get that player that's
falling a little bit
he's giving us some clues there sounds
like he's done a study on that uh how
those top 15 picks flush out huh doesn't
it sound like that
well the higher you draft the easier it
is to fill out all the possible
permutations of how the picks are going
to go and it sounds like if maybe a
quarterback sneaks past the top ten yeah
and into 11 12 13 territory then that's
when somebody's going to be getting a
phone call whether it's joe judge
at number 11 getting a phone call judge
and gettleman the coach in gm
respectively with the new york giants
they're at number 11 whether it's howie
roseman at number 12 right although
there's some chatter of the eagles
trying to get back into round one i i
just wonder whether that's all just a
setup and it's brian flores the dolphins
coach who gets a call at number six if
lance is still there trey lance is still
there or maybe even a justin fields at
six i can't imagine that happening
because it's the same division but
remember it was drew bledsoe who was
traded by bill belichick 20 years ago to
the buffalo bills for a first round pick
so i think belichick is willing to
forget about who he's doing business
with if there's a move he wants to make
even if it's a rival
if if that helps him get the guy he
wants he'll go get the guy he wants the
question is how high would he go and who
is the guy he wants and those are the
things we're not going to know until it
happens yeah no you're not yeah i mean
i'm with you mike and the fact that i
don't think he's going to care about
doing business with somebody in the
division or anything like that you know
if he looks at it like hey this this is
the right price they're not trying to
hold my feet over the fire and i have
this need to move to the trade up and do
that i don't think he's gonna care he's
gonna do what he's been best for his own
football team as far as that that
conversation goes and you know again
that's why
i i that's why i took trey lance with
new england before in our last little
exercise at the top of the hour that's
to me i can envision that happening you
know lance being on the board you know
in the early teens 10 11 somewhere in
there and belichick going okay wait i
like this guy and you know if we're
going to talk about the position i think
the patriots need more than any going in
this draft it is quarterback they got to
have some sort of quarterback whether
it's a quarterback of the future maybe
even the backup quarterback as we go
forward because i don't know you know
where jared siddom stands but either way
i think quarterback has to be addressed
within this draft and i would think that
the patriots are thinking about it at 15
and if not at 15 maybe making a move you
know
in the second round to get up there
towards the end of the first or top of
the second to make a move to get a
quarterback then
it's also possible to read his comments
where he seems to be hitting very
strongly that if one of the quarterbacks
slips past 10 he may make a move up
he may actually be hoping that all five
guys definitely are gone by the time
he's on the clock at 15 because he wants
to see
how far he can take it with cam newton
we act like cam newton's been around
forever he was drafted 10 years ago this
month yeah there's still plenty of gas
in the tank and my understanding is
belichick loves cam newton loves
everything about cam newton doesn't love
the fact that he got covered last year
and it kind of threw the season off the
rails but loves what cam newton has done
loves what he can do loves how he's
respected by the teammates and and
remember it's that personality we said
last year when he signed with the
patriots it was the perfect personality
to walk in the door as the quarterback
after tom brady walked out so they may
not feel that compulsion to go after one
of the top quarterbacks it may be like
you said a guy later that they can
develop and maybe flip if need be we saw
him flip ryan mallett we saw him flip
jimmy garoppolo that's right you get it
yeah round three round four
as a guy you develop but if cam newton
has this tremendous second act in his
30s with the patriots you can you can
move on from that guy in a couple years
yeah i listen i don't think they're
they're not gonna like you know sell the
house and the kitchen sink and
everything like that just to get a
quarterback because they need a
quarterback no they're never gonna be
like that belichick's not gonna overpay
for anything and you know i'll second
you know what you said
yeah anything i've ever gotten from new
england is how much they like cam newton
and respect him and everything you know
that he brought to the table like you
said so i don't think they're scared in
any way with the fact that he's their
quarterback and he could be their
quarterback going into this year that
they they think they could still be
successful with him there's no doubt uh
i do expect them to address the
quarterback situation at some point
during the draft it's just when and it's
going to be interesting to see who and
when they make that move for
i think they definitely need to go
corner because next year either stefan
gilmore or jc jackson won't be there
possibly both won't be there jackson
last week signing his one year tender as
a restricted free agent three and a half
million thereabouts
free agent unrestricted next year unless
they would use the franchise tag which
they likely won't do he walks away they
better be ready to plug someone else in
and this is an opportunity at some at
some point in this draft to get a guy
that they would feel good about putting
on the field as a starter in year two i
i would think that they're they're
thinking of that certainly i mean yeah
it's a position they're always looking
to replenish or keep you know keep it
fresh with talented young bodies and
everything like that they're still
pretty deep there at that position
there's no doubt you know but you're
right they got to worry about jc jackson
hey he's he's big time he plays like he
did it last year he's you're gonna have
to pay him you know top top of the
market type money for the corner
position and mike just why we're on that
like no joke that whole like second
round tender stuff and all that that
crap's gotta go you wanna talk about a
stupid thing a stupid vehicle that kills
nfl players like you wanna talk about
that's like it's collusion oh we're
gonna sign him as a high tender because
we know
wink wink there's an unwritten rule
where you don't really try to sign those
kind of guys from us we don't it's bs
the whole second and third round tender
thing like why why wouldn't someone out
there this year who really needs a
corner not to like offer jc jackson
money and write it try to stick it to
the patriots oh you want to sign all
these free agents oh try to now pay jc
jackson along with that you know first
off i wouldn't be playing that game if i
was a gm or a coach i'd be like no no
this rule's here screw your player i
don't care what you tendered or not
we're going to try to steal them deal
with it screw off and it's bs from the
player standpoint sorry i had to get
that off my chest they've been bothering
me for a while hey uh we talked about
this last week on pftpm and i wrote
about it jc jackson's camp called every
team and they would have signed any
offer sheet they'd gotten that was more
than what the patriots were offering
this year even on a one-year deal
multi-year deal make us an offer no one
would do it and there's that sense out
there not universally but there is that
sense that we don't touch theirs yes
they don't touch ours
the second round tender came along ten
years ago
no player with a second round tender
restricted free agent has ever
signed an offer sheet with another team
and it makes even more ludicrous the
fact that the rams used a first round
tender on cornerback darius williams and
paid him an extra million and a half
when they didn't have to nobody's
touching second round players they're
just not doing it and if they were ever
going to do it they were going to do it
with jc jackson so that that is a
strange development you're right that
needs to go but the cba is around for a
decade buffalo bills real quickly
because they're stocked they don't have
a fourth round pick this year they get
their fifth first round pick back last
year their first round pick became
stefan diggs
what's what's their number one need
going into this draft i mean i i look at
buffalo and i think it's it's pretty
easy for me where i just go like edge
they need people to come off the edge
they're just they're just not enough you
know jerry hughes up there in age you
know there's no force
uh as far as anybody notable that you
worry about you know aj epinessa they
drafted him last year in the second
round he's not really a great pass
rusher that way you know mario addison
didn't deliver through them in a big way
last year they need something along
those lines they need a guy who can come
off the edge and be a one-on-one
mismatch nightmare
and be that type of football player for
their defense to me that's something
they got to address at some point in the
early first rounds
i i i hate to be a broken record on this
and i'm a i'm a firm believer in not
having too much
emotion
draft capital and money tied up in one
position but
they've got their jim kelly they've got
their andre reid they really could use a
thurman thomas yeah they really could
you know well that's what they're hoping
for zach moss right they drafted him
last year in the second round and they
need him to
you know be a force you're right i mean
that's certainly something they can't
they can't like what what i think you're
getting to mike and we had this
conversation during the season last year
a little bit
like that i just you can't i don't think
they can realistically just say are we
gonna really play that way again where
it's just gonna be you're gonna drop
back 40 plus times not even worry about
the run game remember like they played
seattle and seattle was like remember
pete carroll's comments after the game
he's like yeah they didn't even really
care about the run like they just threw
it every play like i think he was i i
that that to me is not realistic and i
can't imagine mcdermott wanting to play
that style of football like to your
point the run games got to be more
effective this year for buffalo
yeah i agree with you now that they know
what josh allen can do the question is
figuring out how to do it the best
possible way and balancing you got to
have balance in that offense yeah or
you're not going to be able to get it
done when the games get as important as
we saw the bills play most meaningful
games they've played in in a very very
long time and they should be back at
that level again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports